jean michel meyer on a pigé des anonymes
en leur faisant croire qu'ils
participent à une nouvelle émission qui
s'appelait shihri ce soir on va dîner
chez une star et malheureusement pour
eux cette star c'est jean-michel mais
jean michel maire je pouvais dire je
crois qu'on a un nouveau concept
cette caméra cachée regardez c'est très
très fort c'est parti
[Musique]
installez-vous
thématique est donc bonjour à tous et
bienvenue notre nouvelle émission chéri
on va donner celle d'une star
donc on vous a déjà expliqué le principe
vous allez chez quelqu'un vous
découvrirez star au moment où je fais
une bonne émission
oh c'est quoi le délire attend ils ont
dit qu'ils avaient des indices observés
autour de vous bah déjà mais qu'importe
si je pensais qu'ils allaient prendre
pour aller chez toi c'est bien la tête
on va manger chez m keynes web à savoir
ses maîtres gouvernance ajoute je crois
que c'est vraiment maître gims ans ouais
ça doit être un mec un vieux à cinq ans
mme badache lancement puisque ça
j'espère que c'est pas un jeu une des
stars comme imagine toi c'est michelle
saintout petit chat remis ça va soit tu
bonjour jean michel lheureux louzac
ailleurs bienvenue pour la première de
schering ce soir on dîne chez une star
online star on fait ce qu'on passe la
première web en ait pas trop de moyens
pour la première salut ma couille je
tapais makoun qui commet en ton prénom
nice nice nice - et toi quand tony
anthony nice ça ça va très jolie jessica
et jessica frais je veux aussi j'ai de
l'argent ce soit séibou bienvenue chez
moi
vous arrivez d'où ils y ont tous ou à
lui on est de lyon il sera quand vous
êtes en couple
oui ça m'arrange pas d'y faire la loi
c-11 couple croisé
oui c'est ça c'est pas innocent comme
placement pourquoi ah bah quand on
croise déjà début du repas c'est que à
une soirée peut être là
super plaisir de vous accueillir vous
attendiez à qui je m'attendais à une
star voilà un mot clover maître gims
autre chose à [ __ ] ce soit moi je
m'attendais à cirer s'est rassuré et a
aussi assuré la syrie j'ai pas dit ça va
durer mais il avec daniel braud ça peut
être tellement longtemps qu'on n'a pas
vu loupe à la nourrir c'est l'heure d'un
instant à pire en haut vous avez soif
bâché pas moins de 10 kg 200 rôles que
c'est jean michel camdessus s'énoncer
bon délire c'est par une petite
franchement il n'est grave conflit
enfin après une mort à deux vitesses tu
vois une aura des victimes et zepa les
finir
alors on n'est pas là pour ça c'est la
france mais qui lobe de la maison c'est
moi
bon je vais désolé j'ai belge est pas
sorti de la retirer l'eau pour l'apéro
j'ai pu se concentrer les moyens sur le
dîner voilà voilà qu'est ce que je me
sers façon qu'elle se rend compte qu'il
est une franchement on aurait pu faire
un effort quand même de me convaincre
les couverts en argent comptant 21 il ya
un couple sur deux je pense qu'il ya un
train déjà deux parties un peu haut il
ya un peu de routine s'installer dit pas
contre et anthony que
tu pensé à toi sont là de ma santé ops
colonel la chaise queen à mort et du
coup pour le micro sa mentalité bien
mais pas discute avec les des champions
ce que vous voulez pas ça ça va tu as tu
me kiffe pas trop je reste si ça va
devenir des sprints aniston au sein des
ponts pourquoi wade a été ouvert
d'esprit
prenez un peu quand même merci merci
donc du coup moi je chante j'aime le
changer parce que du coup avec le micro
ça va vas-y c'est trop chaud tarifs des
quatre modes sur la table époux jacques
tu t'énerves pour des trucs comme ça
c'est rien ou quoi je suis pas jaloux
mais j'aime pas mais tu aimes pas quoi
un synthé son délire c'est jean-michel
je crois c'est qui les parrainent fois
encore tu m'aurais dit tu es jeune homme
de charisme ou bah ouais mais là
les varennes pas mal mais pas trop dans
les bacs
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
chez moi c'est comme ça non mais c'est
une blague
ailleurs c'est cross non mais ça c'est
quoi cette tenue je vois pas bon pour
ses invités et on est franchement quand
je salue ici ils ont déchanté n'est pas
beau ça c'est à des chaussures de
protection de se rassembler moi je
trouve ça bien bizarre c'est quoi une
longueur de gecko neigé que des
vendanges et à leurs patients
mais il ya un jeu aussi le moment de
l'animation animations nous c'est le jeu
de l'apéro ya pas de vous inquiéter pas
passé que dan ar cas il n'y a pas de
traquenard technique c'est très inquiet
il y à deux doigts de merci monsieur
joaillerie c'était une piñata mais c'est
une binya tard à ma façon je dois me
battre
y'a pas de finir son bâton 1 nos avants
ne pourront pas tapé dans le mille à 3
vous avez retiré les mondes au hockey et
après vous permettrez pourront jouer
d'accord un deux trois six et vous donne
un conseil visé par le
fonté vous et les vignerons et les
surprises sont plutôt dans les locaux et
là on peut taper fort à gauche la gauche
dans ma promotion forcément
à ce jeu là
de base il entend le bouille bien mais
on sait bien que c'est bien mieux au cou
mais non même abattu pas être foutu et
tu mets tes mains dans une mauvaise
[Applaudissements]
passe des personnalisations cristiano
quel sens cela mais surtout spéciales
comme échange trois prochains mois en
garde mais je pensais que c'était un
jour à rogard envoyée au couvent femme
est trop bon bravo les années en tout
cas vous avez bien mérité pour moi en
thibert un petit nom cette fois ci de
jessica et a et e et de lège les servir
le dîner ok et là j'ai un peu tout misé
sur le dîner est là je pense que je vais
marquer des points bon mais on espère
avoir c'est le moment de passer à table
c'est le clou du spectacle
super nanny le gpac vous avez faim le
niveau va vous avez grand fin à ces
bonnes âmes après ce sera à moi ok vous
version chic comme vous voulez moi j'ai
plein de voix recouvrement du nom
j'appréhende aussi vous allez voyager
c'est le voyage initiatique jean duboc m
on attend de voir ça bon j'espère que
vous aimez la news pourquoi puis cette
tentation et cachemire ou non la
tentation cachemire le tentation et
cachemire cachemires scène régionale
ok tu as on les cache pierre tentation
cachemire car j'arrête heureux comme
vêtement avec gachon energy star wayne
non maintenant tout ce à quoi je pense
les choux
je suis nantais dégueulasse mentionne un
jeu
t'as vu c'est bizarre sinon moi je vais
m'acheter un grec séquence actuelle ces
indiens seront pas traduits
bonne journée à fontenoy mais je préside
a fait cette commission c'est pas
évident mais franchement j'ai mangé le
mec me concernant mais après quand tu
rentres 3 rue jean jaurès est ravi c'est
mon pote rami amis comment s'appelle le
mode je suis aujourd'hui c'est qu'on
connaît grecs en sont du cachemire est
en entrée on a du cerveau ça du chichi
kebab ici du poulet avec d'une haine du
chenal et puis en accompagnement des
légumes on est censé manger ça ça la
cloche à vache ça c'est faut pas y
toucher c'est le tigre qui pleure mais
ça c'est pour quelqu'un de sexy et celle
ci voulait pas c'est bon il fait un peu
de pub c'est lui qui a lancé le concept
appareils et tu peux faire tout donner
pour me faire un japonais
mais tu as toutes et à tous les la
société comme ça génial mais si tu
manges exergue
moi je commence toujours par le premier
temps de dori
non il n'est pas sérieux la tranche
langues ça vous dérange corse a lui même
poids sur la table ça s'étire auditeurs
ça c'est terrible mais franchement je
m'en fous moi que celui-ci aurait pu
être moi mais franchement maintenant je
mange pas non mais mangent pas venu ici
pour faire ça franchement ça c'est
n'importe quoi
les fait rire ce sont vos thèmes sans
matière grasse voulait même pas goûté
quoi franchement céder ses biens
[Musique]
evans sérieusement là ça me fait plus
rire là on arrive on trouve des capots
de sur la table à ckoi ça mange pas venu
pour ça c'était drôle au début mais là
c'est plus humain en fait c'est ça me
fait peur pour toi en plus elle ça
attendez vous à démontrer on prend ça
m'intéresse plus et on met le dessert
non ok mais quelle dose tu va nous
ramener quoi si c'est pas grave mais
c'est pas drôle français c'est pas mal
mais c'est je t'aime pas vrai au début
c'était drôle mais là c'est plus marrant
non
blessé aussi tu veux pas laisser de gc
qui a mangé tout ça le tir est hyper je
veux dire à cuba fâché c'est pas une
nouvelle émission c'est pour la grande
race track cyril hanouna se tenir à
cacher
[Applaudissements]
alors moi je crois qu'il faudrait il est
l'ami
j'arrive
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci merci beaucoup et vous êtes
magnifique tous les deux et tu l'as pas
qui fait un ouais si j'ai kiffé mais il
a sous les halles à farid assouly le
début c'était bien mais puisque et elle
elle te calmes heureusement que tu étais
là oui heureusement voyez il voulait
vraiment venir un ouais merci les amis
dans un vrai resto après c'est vrai